good morning believe nation today's
message is experiment over to you Bob
Ross probably nothing will teach you
more than just experimenting there's
many different things as you have the
nerve to do you just go for it there
sometimes you learn more from mistakes
than you do from trying so hard so
anytime you any time you make a mistake
before you get upset with it look at it
sometimes those mistakes turning to be
the best learning devices we have there
we are and I meant to know one of the
other shows maybe even a different
series I don't remember I get letters
from people who say they're just not
satisfied with what they're doing that
they're painting just just not coming
out the way they want I think if there's
a secret to human nature it's the fact
that we aren't satisfied we're never
satisfied i hope you hope you're
absolutely plagued with dissatisfaction
through your whole life because if you
are you'll always strive to do better
and over and over I tell my students if
you ever do a painting you're completely
satisfied with you might as well quit
because you have nowhere else to go if
you stop experimenting your business
that's when it's going to fail if you
just stay in the safe zone of what has
always work and you stop trying new
things out your business is going to
fail if you look at anybody who's had
tremendous success in their life in the
career as an entrepreneur you'll point
to the people who have the most success
of the ones who experiment the most to
they try more stuff they feel out a lot
more stuff and they eventually hit on
things that work this is why I tell you
guys that need to be prolific and that
whatever you are doing whatever you want
to learn you need to be prolific at it
to practice to experiment to get better
to fail to learn how to add more value
you if you're doing something once a
week then you're not going to really get
good at it quickly if you want to learn
a language you want to pick up a new
skill you know once a week is not going
to be enough you'll slowly incrementally
get better at it probably but if it's
important to you this is a really
important goal for you then you need to
be prolific if you want to learn
marketing that's the thing that you
really want to do market is going to be
really important to your company you
have a passion for it you need to
immerse yourself into it you need to
practice you can be prolific you need to
try a whole bunch of different things
you need to experiment and you'll get
really good at it but if you're not
creating enough if you're not doing
enough test if you're not trying enough
you're not going to get good at it it's
going to be mediocre and slowly start
getting better and better and better and
so if it's important for you then you
need to practice and you need to
experiment I would also encourage you
not to worry so much about getting the
perfect thing out perfectionism stops
you from making any kind of progress
it's holding you where you are the
attempts to try to make the perfect
thing is an unattainable goal it will
never be perfect it will always be
better there's always a way to make
things better it's never perfect making
this video is not perfect as much as
I've done you know 4,000 videos that
have led me to this point to make this
video for you guys I could still get way
better the oven from 2020 is going to
look back on this video and say man I
was so bad what a bad video look at what
i was doing look at how i was acting
what they're always saying I'm so much
better now i can't believe that video is
up it's fine because when you are
prolific in your content creation or
whatever you're trying to do when you're
creating so much and you continue to
practice the one video that you make
doesn't matter if i'm trying to practice
learning italian the one conversation I
have with somebody doesn't matter it's
part of a bigger picture part of my
entire growth the individual piece that
you're creating your investing time
you're investing energy and dressing
your heart you're trying to make it the
best thing you can make it with the
skills and resources that you have right
now that's it that's the most important
thing and realize that tomorrow can be
a little bit better in the next deal is
look better if you continue to hustle
then in 12 24 36 months you're going to
be way better and then you're still
going to drive you're going to still
continue there is no end point you want
to continue to get better because it's
an important goal for you and you do it
by continuing to experiment so the
question today today is I'm curious what
new experiments are you going to try
today in your business or your life and
you've been putting off you're a little
bit scared of you feeling may not be
good enough or ready for yet how can you
start it some small experiment leave it
down the comments below super curious to
find out what that is and by sharing it
publicly hopefully that gives you the
push to actually go and do it I also
want to give a quick shout out to Rafael
more Rafael thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book you're
wrong word really really means a lot to
me and i hope you enjoying it so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot i
benchpress hey believe nation for those
of you looking for a little more
inspiration to experiments here are some
bonus clips that I think you'll enjoy I
don't make notes I don't I react very
instinctively to everything I'm a great
believer in traveling a great deal I
don't believe meeting more than two
people in a meeting with too many I true
do you know about stand up ok so in
Silicon Valley now when you have a
meeting everybody stands in a circle
like they're meditating and then
that's how maybe I should try that I I
think the more you go out the more you
see the more you experience life and
more you bring back to your day job so
as I was trying to say in my remarks I
think the problem that big corporations
is you get a lot of people my age trying
to hold on to their jobs and you know
clinging onto their pensions and their
retirement and they're not experiencing
new things and they don't like change
and they don't like disruption so
they're either they don't make a
decision or they say no and as a result
they stagnate so it's terribly important
to bring people in from the outside and
not to remain q insular and also to hire
as many young bright people like all of
you as you can just good people have to
think about things completely
differently I think the secret to my
career is I don't know what I can't do
you know they be taught there are times
when I should probably sit and think but
i really want to jump you know jump out
there with Philip Seymour I mean with
Riley and and and sing you know the
night Chicago died or don't really want
to play the blues with little adore you
know and I you just do it you just do
these things and and you become the
audience wants you to do these things
yeah I think what's what's I don't know
what it is but I think over the years
people have gotten comfortable with the
notion that I try things it's almost
their desk and they're not worried about
me do you know what I mean I I think
that's the key people aren't worried
about me getting hurt because I can you
know i'll give it a hundred percent and
then if it completely falls on its face
i'll laugh about it and move on and i
think there's a little bit of a sense
after all these years people say you
know all right he tried it maybe it
worked maybe it didn't work but he had a
good time and for you you can come back
the next night in the next night in the
next month mmhmm yeah i mean that's you
know the I don't know there's a there's
a there's a over the years I've realized
that there are a lot of
comedians that are very you know worried
about keeping their dignity intact you
know and keeping their personal space
and keeping their sense of authority and
for better or worse and it might be
worse I don't have that you know you
don't I mean I'm not the people that
I've always liked growing up and I'm not
just talking about late-night community
i'm talking about anybody in movie in
film and you know the people I liked
Peter Sellers they would let it all hang
out he just go you know if you look at a
lot of those old classic Carson clips
he's jumping into hot tubs was done with
Don Rickles he's jumping through fake
walls he's you know he's falling on his
ass he's dressed as Floyd turbo and you
know so sometimes I look back to that
and I remembered well you know Johnny
Johnny just just went for it so you know
for better or worse you know I'll try
I'll get out there and I'm very physical
and I my wife is always horrified I'm
always coming out of the shower just
covered in bruises and she'll say what
was that I'll say oh I did a bit you
know we had you know Jeff Garlin on the
show and he and I rolled down a flight
of steps you know and I and I hit a fire
hydrant